[Musik]
sebastian will den nutella code knacken
was ist das geheimnis hinter dem
unverwechselbaren geschmack auf der
suche nach dem ursprung der zutaten
stoßen wir auf fragwürdige tricks von
ferrero
[Musik]
das große geheimnis
ich versuche den teller code zu knacken
ist supereinfach das original absolut
gehütetes geheimnis aber was die können
kann ich schon lange
laut ferrero stecken in der nuss nougat
creme nur wenige zutaten vanillinzucker
haselnüsse palmöl und magermilchpulver
dazu kakao und ein emulator ich werde
jetzt erstmal meine nüsse posten weil
nur geröstete nüsse entfalten ihren
intensiven geschmack und nüsse sind
teuer
dann braucht man weniger man pusht das
aroma nach oben und wir wollen ja so nah
ran wie es nur geht also feuer frei weil
ich habe einen speziellen rest automaten
mitgebracht
[Musik]
schön die nüsse langsam rüsten der
flammenwerfer marke eigenbau wird fast
1000 grad heiß sebastian lege braucht
viel fingerspitzengefühl damit die
haselnüsse nicht verbrennen ja ich würde
sagen die sind jetzt schon goldgelb
gerüstet einfach dadurch ihr doppeltes
aroma und daraus müssen wir mut machen
weil so richtig schön feiern werden die
nüsse werden auch in der fabrik solange
gemahlen bis ein zartes ruß entsteht
sebastian ist fertig wenn sich im mixer
haselnussöl gebildet hat
hey sieht richtig gut aus richtig cremig
das hat schon mal funktioniert in einem
keller stecken 13% haselnüsse diesen
teuer deshalb setzt die rettung strecken
allem fett
es ist in der industrie beliebt weil es
cremig und sehr günstig ist ein schön
neutrales fed wo sich jeglicher
geschmack auf zaubern lässt deswegen
auch so beliebt in der nutella cacau
sorgt für die richtige optik emulgator
für die bindung vanillin milchpulver
haselnuss und flüssiges kein fett
unterstützen den geschmack und ja ein
bisschen zucker ein bisschen zucker ganz
schön viel aber zucker ist ganz wichtig
zucker sorgt für haltbarkeit und auch
hier wieder für die stabilität wenn
zuckerwaren verrührt wird und wieder
erkaltet ergibt dass auch diese schöne
cremigkeit
und die richtige süße see genutzt die
puder variante die lässt sich schneller
und einfacher verrühren
es sieht das gut aus konsistenz passt
geschmack passt von ob das meine
testesser herausfinden welche ist das
original ist und welches mal nachbau da
bin ich richtig gespannt
ich glaube die schmecken das nicht raus
sebastian macht den blindtest mit
passanten die original nutella serviert
er auf löffeln mit einem roten punkt
los geht es mit seiner kreation auf den
blau markierten lassen
sehr süß schon sind muss ich schokolade
okay schokoladig muss sich die nüsse
hatte sebastian extra an gerüstet was
sagen die tester zum roten löffel mit
dem original von ferrero also da muss
ich sagen dies wesentliche sonko wird
vor sage man schmeckt zucker aber okay
viel intensiver im geschmack
wahrscheinlich so lustig wie das andere
san sebastians blauer löffel die marke
schlagen was schmeckt auch besser sagen
[Musik]
ich finde dass musiker besseren ganz
eigentlich ist das blaue aha und du
sagst rot-rot 22 dabei bleibt es nur
zwei der zehn tester fanden sebastian
scream besser
der rest dagegen das original
[Musik]
fehlgeschlagen gibt weiter
den teller kommt hat sebastian legen
nicht knacken kann
was ist das geheimnis von ferreros
rezepturen die stiftung warentest lobt
die qualität der verwendeten rohstoffe
sind besonders gute müsse die lösung die
haselnüsse für nutella werden laut
ferrero unter anderem in italien
angebaut
im piemont der heimatregion des konzerns
wurde während des zweiten weltkrieges
erstmals die tour nutella hergestellt
cacau war mangelware
deshalb behalte sich firmengründer
pietro ferrero mit haselnüssen
die wachsen in der region im unmengen
ganz in der nähe von piräus hauptsitz
besuchen wir eine plantage simone vola
baut gemeinsam mit seiner mutter carola
haselnüsse an
sie sortieren die besten müssen per hand
aus
daraus entsteht feinstes haselnuss muss
das zu passten und pralinen wird
stecken diese italienischen müsse in
ferreros nutella bis vor etwa vier
jahren haben wir an ferrero geliefert
dann haben wir aber begonnen aus unseren
haselnüssen eigene produkte herzustellen
bevor wir diese umstellung gemacht haben
gingen unsere nüsse an ferrero doch
ferrero hat die preise immer weiter
gesenkt zum schluss erhielt familie wohl
noch 500 euro für 100 kilo nüsse für
ferrero war das aber immer noch zu teuer
denn an der türkischen schwarzmeerküste
liegt der preis für 100 kilo haselnüsse
eine rund 230 euro
für den konzern kann der preis unter
umständen noch geringer ausfallen
denn das unternehmen ist der bei weitem
größte abnehmer türkischer haselnüsse
von keinem anderen unternehmen ist die
türkische branche so abhängig
[Musik]
über eine halbe million tonnen werden
jährlich geerntet
allein ferrero nimmt zwei drittel davon
ab um möglichst hochwertige ware zu
bekommen hat ferrero 2014
außerdem das größte türkische
unternehmen zur gewinnung verarbeitung
und vermarktung von haselnüssen
aufgekauft kurzum an ferrero führt kein
weg vorbei
diese marktmacht drückt den preis für
erzeuger bleibt dadurch nicht viel übrig
die folge die arbeitsbedingungen von
erntehelfern sind extrem schlecht auch
syrische kinder sollen auf türkischen
haselnuss plantagen arbeiten
berichte darüber häufen sich wir
konfrontieren den konzern mit der
problematik und möchten wissen ob
kinderarbeit auf haselnuss plantagen
sicher ausgeschlossen werden kann
das unternehmen schreibt ferrero ist
sich bewusst dass dies eine
schwachstelle in der
landwirtschaftlichen lieferkette in der
türkei ist nach den derzeit verfügbaren
daten hatten wir in der türkei bis ende
2018 eine rückverfolgbarkeit von 45
prozent für unsere haselnüsse erzielt
[Musik]
demnach kann ferrero seine lieferkette
für haselnüsse nicht verlässlich
kontrollieren
kinderarbeit kann das unternehmen nicht
ausschließen
wir animieren den konzern dazu das
problem durch höhere löhne zu lesen
darauf erhalten wir keine antworten
haselnüsse scheinen für ferrero keine
option zu sein folgt rohstoff trick
nummer zwei nutella wird nur durch viel
fett cremig und streichzart haselnüsse
aber sind teuer und enthalten zu wenig
öl
deshalb setzt ferrero in großen mengen
ein anderes feld ein
pauli fast alle ferrero produkte
enthalten das feld aus tropischen
billiglohnländern
der konzern kaufte vor allem in malaysia
indonesien und papua neu guinea ein
palmöl hat den vorteil dass es auf wenig
fläche sehr viel ertrag bietet und
wächst natürlich auch in ländern wo die
löhne der arbeiter nicht besonders hoch
sind dass dieses fett ist wirklich sehr
sehr günstig doch umweltschützer
schlagen alarm denn palmöl wird meist in
riesigen monokulturen angebaut
aus ökologischer sicht sind monokulturen
generell problematisch dazu gibt es auch
studien beispielsweise von der uni
zürich die eben sagen das ja
monokulturen effizient zu bewirtschaften
sind aber mit vielerlei negativen folgen
für die für die umwelt und auch für die
ja für die artenvielfalt wo heute palmöl
in monokulturen angebaut wird stand
früher meist regenwald die abholzung ist
ein schwerer schlag für das weltklima
auch der lebensraum vieler tierarten
wurde zerstört
sogar die entstehung neuer pandemien
kann möglicherweise auf das roden von
regenwald zurückgeführt werden
[Musik]
allein ferrero bezieht jährlich 200.000
tonnen palmöl wir wollen wissen wurde
auch für ferrero produkte regenwald
abgeholzt
ferrero bezieht sein palmöl von mehreren
großhändlern unsere recherche zeigt
sieben dieser unternehmen machen
umstrittene geschäft
sie kaufen bei lokalen ölmühlen ein die
regenwald durch brandrodung vernichtet
haben soll
diese praktik ist besonders umwelt
zerstörend und rücksichtslos greenpeace
stützt die vorwürfe gegen die
großhändler von denen ferrero kauft
[Musik]
wir konfrontieren den konzern mit den
rechercheergebnissen ferrero antwortet
von sieben der aufgeführten unternehmen
haben im zweiten halbjahr nur vier an
ferrero geliefert infolgedessen haben
wir jedes von ihnen kontaktiert um zu
prüfen ob die mühlen die ferrero
beliefern
zu den im greenpeace bericht genannten
gehören keine von ihnen gehört dazu
[Musik]
ferrero gibt also zu viel der sieben
fragwürdigen unternehmen liefern palmöl
für nutella und co angeblich stammt es
aber nicht von durch brandrodung
entstandenen plantagen einen beweis
dafür bleibt ferrero schuldig verweist
stattdessen auf sein engagement für
soziale und ökologische standards beim
anbau sauberes palmöl kann so aber nicht
garantiert werden
umweltschützer sehen das grundlegende
problem in den verschlungenen
lieferketten ferrero ist ein unternehmen
das sich sehr intensiv mit seiner per
kette beschäftigt trotzdem solange es
von großen agrar händlern kaufte die
wiederum von produzenten kaufen die
weiterhin mit der zerstörung von
regenwäldern mit brandrodung in
verbindung stehen solange es auch
ferrero spa lieferkette nicht sauber
ferien nutzt seine marktmacht und kaufte
rohstoffe besonders günstig ein
das geht am ende zulasten von arbeitern
und der umwelt ein fragwürdiger trick
des unternehmens
was ist eure liebste nuss nougat creme
und viel wichtiger der die oder das
nutella sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mit neuer essen wissen
wollt dann abonnier zdf besser esser und
schaut in die nächsten zwei clips